club still going to the club don't waste  my  time  time people who are still partying and  playing those tracks that put you in the  la la land tell them don't waste my  time friends who are inviting you to get  back to getting pimped by shaytan to the  alcohol to the drinks to the party to  the drugs to the moral decay and  corruption things that corrupt the heart  mind body and soul tell them don't waste  my  time  time to the kim kardashians and the dj  khaleds tell them i don't want to be  part of it don't waste my  time or you got friends who remind you  of your true purpose in life your  creator when you mess up they remind you  of the hereafter they remind you of when  it's time for salah when it's time for  prayer or they're trying to get you out  of hijab into some tawdry dress tell  them don't waste my  time  time jenna's on my mind nothing is over  nothing now my brothers and sisters